[Music]
he is continuously kicking other
officers just because you have a
prosthetic leg or you may be handicapped
does not means that you cannot actively
fight police officers or not use one of
your prosthetic legs at the weapon if
that's policing where a man who's
handicapped and his half naked on the
street is policing policing you're not
policing you don't even have enough
respect to pull his pants up I've been
shooting this for almost ten minutes and
saying that and they just pulled up his
pants now believe that I've ever had an
altered mental state and he fit the
criteria for mental health attention
[Music]
you